una delle parole
e trans
transizione deriva da
indica quindi momento di passaggio da
una condizione ad un'altra siamo nel
contesto della transizione ecologica
quindi un contesto di passaggio da un
vecchio mondo basato sul carbonio
fossile un nuovo mondo invece pos
carbonio
non abbiamo una bacchetta magica che ci
potrà far fare questo salto in avanti
questo percorso improvviso verso questo
mondo che stiamo provando a immaginare e
costruire e necessario che tutti e
ciascuno abbiano la consapevolezza di
quello che è necessario fare per
incamminarsi verso verso questo nuovo
mondo e ciascuno ovviamente secondo le
proprie competenze capacità ma
soprattutto secondo il proprio ruolo in
modo tale che si arrivi a un modello un
nuovo modello ambientalmente sostenibile
abbiamo addirittura cambiato il nome del
ministero dell'ambiente per sottolineare
l'urgenza di questo tempo e
gran parte dei fondi del pnr r
saranno destinati a progetti proprio su
questi temi c'è un grande entusiasmo
soprattutto in certi ambienti ci sono
libri trasmissioni televisive corsi e
così via ma l'impressione che su larga
scala ci sia poca consapevolezza e poca
comprensione di quello che
effettivamente sta accadendo e dovrà
accadere per fare questa transizione
non c'è una bacchetta magica
ho detto eppure in molti soprattutto
anche a livello governativo
fanno molto affidamento sulla tecnologia
su una o più innovazioni tecnologiche
che potranno farci fare proprio un salto
diretto deciso in avanti cancellando
tutti i problemi che abbiamo
la tecnologia sicuramente importante e
strategica fondamentale
anche in questi giorni sicuramente
stanno nascendo delle startup che grazie
proprio a delle innovazioni tecnologiche
su questi temi diventeranno le grandi
aziende del del domani
e questo è importantissimo perché sarà
necessario creare nuovi posti di lavoro
che vadano a sostituire quelli che
inevitabilmente saranno persi con la
transizione
bisogna però stare attenti
si parla tanto ad esempio di
carbon capture and storage la cattura e
lo stoccaggio della co2 quindi togliere
dall atmosfera la co2 che vi abbiamo
messo per metterla sotto terra magari
nei giacimenti degli idrocarburi ormai
esauriti e ci sono sperimentazioni in
tal senso piuttosto che si parla tanto
anche in questi giorni di fusione
nucleare che una volta pronta ci potrà
dare energia illimitata senza emissioni
non c'è certezza però su queste
tecnologie e
se ci pensate che si arrivi domani alla
fusione nucleare se ne parla da 50 anni
e non c'è certezza appunto e pare
assurdo che ci si affidi a tecnologie
non ancora pronte quando siamo in un
contesto in cui c'è già qualcos'altro di
pronto di accessibile di affidabile
ormai a bassi costi come ad esempio la
produzione di energia da fonti
rinnovabili
è necessario quindi un ridimensionamento
di tutti quelli che sono gli impatti
ambientali perché quando parliamo di
transizione attenzione non stiamo
parlando solo di emissione di carbonio
stiamo parlando anche di tutti gli altri
impatti antropici sul pianeta di tutte
le urgenze ambientali che ci sono mi
riferisco alla deforestazione alla
perdita di biodiversità piuttosto che al
sovrasfruttamento delle risorse naturali
e così via
bisogna ridimensionare i nostri impatti
ma per farlo bisogna ridimensionare le
nostre filiere produttive produzione
energetica industriale manifatturiera
perché è bene ricordarlo è il modello
estrazione produzione consumo modello
lineare che ha portato a tutti gli
sconvolgimenti in impatti di cui stiamo
parlando ed è necessario che il nostro
modello economico
subisca una transizione subiscano nella
parola giusta faccia un passo appunto
verso una transizione che possa piegare
questa linea e fare diventare il modello
circolare ed è necessario che questo
questo passaggio venga fatto da tutti e
da ciascuno dai singoli dalle famiglie
delle comunità delle città andando a
cercare di capire quanto il proprio
stile di vita e le proprie azioni
quotidiane possano
per seguire modelli circolari e
diventare più leggeri nei confronti
dell'ambiente
e necessario però capire quali sono
quindi gli impatti e perché se io do
consapevolezza se io ricevo
consapevolezza su questi temi poi ho
bisogno di poter fare delle scelte però
di pensare andando al supermercato
adesso uno scaffale se devo scegliere un
prodotto
trovo diverse marche e diversi prezzi
ovviamente è al di là delle
caratteristiche intrinseche del prodotto
stesso non ho altri strumenti di scelta
pensate invece se avessi un etichetta
ambientale che mi dice di quel prodotto
quant'è l'impatto sul suo ciclo di vita
e sappiamo bene che molti consumatori
noi siamo pronti a fare delle scelte che
ci consentono di scegliere un prodotto
meno impattante anche se magari un
prezzo più alto però dobbiamo averle con
informazioni al momento non li abbiamo e
avere consapevolezza e chiedere al
mercato questa informazione è
sicuramente un passaggio importante
perché significherebbe che l'azienda
dovrebbe andare a calcolare quelli che
sono gli impatti sul ciclo di vita del
prodotto stesso
per restituire un etichetta che sia
veritiera
e a quel punto se vuole essere
competitiva sul mercato deve anche
andare a capire come ridurre i propri
impatti per far sì che l'etichetta sia
vantaggiosa e che quindi il consumatore
scelga il suo prodotto quindi tutti
devono capire che cos'è impronta nello
specifico che cos'è la carbon footprint
che è quella
diciamo el'impronta che abbiamo sul
pianeta in termini di emissioni di gas a
effetto serra el'impronta di un prodotto
di un servizio di un'azienda di una
comunità di una persona
a dire il vero come detto ci sono anche
altri impatti non sono solo le emissioni
di gas serra però c'è un'urgenza
in questo senso e abbiamo
in qualche modo come impatto
non solo ciò che noi mettiamo nei
confronti del pianeta ma anche ciò che
noi prendiamo dal pianeta stesso perché
se ci pensate il nostro pianeta
oikos dal greco la nostra casa comune da
cui anche lo studio della nostra casa
l'ecologia
ebbene il nostro pianeta due proprietà
da una parte quella di fornirci le
risorse di cui abbiamo bisogno e
dall'altra quella di assorbire i nostri
scarti ed è evidente che in un contesto
planetario finito
queste due proprietà non sono infinite
quindi c'è una quantità limite che è
limitata fisicamente di risorse che noi
possiamo prendere e c'è un limite nella
quantità di inquinanti che la terra il
pianeta può assorbire e questo questo
limite riconoscere la limitatezza del
pianeta e il passaggio fondamentale per
passare a un modello sostenibile che a
quel modello che ci permettesse di
utilizzare le risorse ma di farlo in
modo tale che queste risorse rimangano
disponibile in futuro significa farlo
rispettando i cicli naturali e significa
anche andare a emettere in una quantità
tale per cui il pianeta possa assorbire
i nostri scarti
se ci pensate anche il cambiamento
climatico è la vera oltrepassato un
limite il limite nella quantità di
emissioni di co2 che la nostra atmosfera
può assorbire quindi abbiamo continuato
emettere le missioni si sono
hanno caricato diciamo la coperta
termica del pianeta che ha trattenuto
sempre più calore dando luogo agli
stravolgimenti del clima quindi è
giustificato questo focus sul carbonio
sì la nostra impronta globale al di là
che ci sono altri impatti come abbiamo
detto è composta per il 57 per cento da
carbonio e quindi è per questo che c'è
questa enfasi sui cambiamenti climatici
e sulle nostre emissioni di gas serra
qualche settimana fa si è conclusa con
26 e di glasgow la grande conferenza
globale sul clima se n'è parlato
tantissimo prima che la conferenza
avesse luogo al termine non ci sono
stati grossi titoli sui giornali sui
risultati ottenuti questo anche perché
delegati osservatori hanno lasciato il
posto
all'entusiasmo iniziale
diciamo la non capacità di riuscire a
dire esattamente se la conferenza fosse
stata un successo un fallimento e anche
i resoconti migliori non hanno saputo
spiegare cosa effettivamente sia
successo ma al di là di questo abbiamo
un obiettivo che è
improcrastinabile
che è quello di ridurre le emissioni
ridurli seguendo un obiettivo specifico
dato dalla scienza del clima e dall ipcc
intergovernamental panel on climate
change che è quello di mantenere
l'aumento delle temperature su scala
globale entro una crescita di 1,5 gradi
questo significherebbe non avere
stravolgimenti tali da distruggere le
nostre comunità le nostre società le
nostre economie significherebbe non
avere
devastazioni climatiche su scala globale
significherebbe mantenere il nostro
livello di benessere
certo poi cui bisognerebbe aprire una
parentesi sul fatto che il nostro
livello di benessere non è il livello di
benessere globale ci sono paesi sulla
terra che hanno ovviamente un livello di
benessere molto minore delle nostre
vogliono cercare di raggiungere il
nostro la nostra ricchezza uno degli
obiettivi di componenti sera proprio
quello di cercare di capire come
accompagnare questi paesi in una
crescita
sostenibile che quindi fosse a bassa
intensità a messina che 20 sia a bassa
intensità missiva è che non è che non si
sa come la nostra crescita come è stata
la nostra crescita
se andiamo a ricostruire il nostro pane
sfero secondo il contributo storico da
parte delle nazioni in termini di
emissioni di co2 vediamo come sia
evidente il contributo del nord del
mondo è questa questa rappresentazione
fa anche capire come le emissioni di co2
di fatto siano un indicatore di
ricchezza un indicatore di benessere
fa vedere come ci sia un'enorme
disequità su scala planetaria legato a
questi temi disequità che peraltro si
riflette anche negli impatti che si
stanno registrando che guarda caso si
stanno registrando per lo più nei paesi
che non hanno contribuito maggiormente a
emettere storicamente e questo tema
della disequità un altro tema
fondamentale
ricordiamocelo che co2 indicatore co2
significa indicatori della nostra
ricchezza del nostro benessere del
nostro stile di vita
quindi siamo ciò che consumiamo siamo
ciò che mangiamo siamo ciò che buttiamo
in termini di rifiuti quindi siamo ciò
che emettiamo
anche se credo nessuno di noi sappia
realmente chi è se stesso se si deve
pensare in termini di emissioni di co2
anche i più attenti non sanno quanto
effettivamente sia il proprio impatto
anche facendo scelte sostenibili tutti i
giorni
vi sfido a conoscere la vostra impronta
personale e quindi è necessario avere
consapevolezza è necessario capire che
si può fare delle scelte a minore
impatto nei confronti del pianeta
bisogna però capire cosa sta dietro a
queste scelte e quindi è necessario
avere consapevolezza su questo perché
ciascuno di unità quando si è alzato
questa mattina ha contribuito al
riscaldamento globale dal gas per il
riscaldamento l'energia elettrica e
trasporti quello che abbiamo mangiato
affi stato buttato tutto concorre a fare
una la nostra impronta l'importante è
essere consapevoli di quello che succede
perché c'è chi è più virtuoso e chi meno
ma non è questo il punto il punto è
poter fare delle scelte basate sulla
consapevolezza e attenzione l'abbiamo
detto non è solo una scelta che ricade
sui singoli e sulle famiglie ma questa
consapevolezza può spingere il mercato
perché è una consapevolezza diffusa può
fare in modo che le aziende il mercato
faccia scelte che poi si riflettono
sulle persone e questo è fondamentale
per venire qui oggi io percorso circa
300 chilometri in macchina da como
quindi ho emesso circa 40 kg di co2 e
altrettanto farò questa sera mi auguro
che questo mio impatto sia giustificato
dall avervi trasmesso un po di voglia di
mettere in gioco le vostre scelte per
portarle verso scelte consapevoli e
sostenibili
[Applauso]